ride through the city like I'm on a
mission to get it ride through the city
like BR if
you and now
Brandon six more
sh what is popping fam I get a little
candy wrestling in my pocket here I wore
these at my son's game I give them
little what are these SAR Patch Kids to
get them up for the games like to sneak
them into the Dugout they're making a
lot of
noise uh what's going on kiddos if
you're watching this maybe you're
driving to work hopefully you're not
watching it as you drive but uh what's
popping man fun weekend we had the cowb
fight companion with Rampage
Jackson um AKA Tenacious D and then we
had Bradley Martin it was a fun one um
can't say the same for the
fights there was a lot of buildup to uh
this entire uh
pay-per-view um I couldn't been more
excited to watch these fights from the
prelims to all the way to the main event
um and there's a lot
of oh how would you put it toxic energy
that was going into this uh card with
the Ian Gary stuff um clearly with Kobe
comington Leon Edwards which uh
magnified everything uh at the press
conference so um it it went down a weird
Road it went down a really weird Road
and I have a theory why I think Kobe
actually crossed the line there
um the the there's a difference between
like the the the in Gary stuff it's kind
of I mean if you're in Gary it's not fun
but it's kind of it's light-hearted It's
a you know it's whatever cuck stuff and
you're like all right the kid can still
fight his ass off and he's you know he's
not even in his prime so you're like all
right he's going to be okay he's going
to figure out I actually think him
getting uh pneumonia was God being like
you know what let's uh kind of chill out
here and let this die down um and they
did announce his fight uh in Miami in
March against Jeff Neil which is uh I'll
take it Jeff Neil over sente luk I'll
take it you know it's
not you know it's not like you supposed
to fight uh shovot and they pulled out
and put in somebody else so it works for
me it's a Miami's fighting soon but I
actually think them the pneumonia thing
I do I know I know nobody thinks it's
real all that I do think he did get sick
his son was sick I from a very very very
reliable source um he was sick I think
this does him uh wonders I think you
know lets everything die down the you
know everyone's a prisoner of the moment
all the the toxic stuff that was on them
sure there's still going to be some
haters that who just you know they they
cing on to something they can't get off
of it for a while you're going to have
those people in the world but for the
most part the MMA media it's a news
cycle it's you know it's a weekly news
cycle so um you know it moved on to
Colby for this week no one's even
talking about eating Gary by Thursday
really once you got announced on
Wednesday that he was out with pneumonia
obviously all the jokes came right and
then Kobe was like hold my bear watch
this and just was like oh all you people
hate Ian Gary come on over here to my
team um with with your hatred and he
just took it to another
level so you forgot about Ian Gary for
for that week and it's only going to get
better for him as the March fight comes
up and then the week of might be a
little something unless he does
something stupid but remember before Ian
Gary before he was the f of the most
hated man in the UFC it was Patty piml
and remember Patty piml got hurt had
that long long layoff what happens you
forget he pops up like oh yeah I like
this guy you totally forget why you
didn't like him or why you sent him a DM
being mean or whatever you messaged on
his Instagram account you're like all
right oh yeah there's Patty I love Patty
Patty's fighting that's cool he's
fighting Tony cool sign me up so
remember Patty it goes through these
waves the MMA Comm is a prisoner of the
moment so Patty pmet was the most hated
guy for a long time especially that
fight that nobody thought he won right
and just the way he handled it wasn't
great and I think he matured over you
know how long ago is that fight Chen
Jared Gordon yeah when you know when he
you know him beating Jared Gordon was
upset people him saying he thought he
beat Jared Gordon upset people then you
had the whole bar stool thing there and
he's asking for a bonus remember and
then por no saying give him the bonus
and it was just like this perfect crap
stor storm for people to be like oh I
don't I'm off the Patty wagon and he was
the yeah no pun intended but he was the
uh the you know the bell of the ball for
a hot second and then it goes so fast
man the community can change on you so
fast and for him I think he learned from
it that was in December 10th uh yeah so
a straight up year off he kind of
chilled out chilled on calling people
out chilled on criticizing people and
that's not Patty Like Pat Patty's a good
kid he has you know as soon as you meet
him The Vibes like he's a special
special person that wasn't him and I
think his team when he got hurt said all
right let's stop all these Antics let's
stop all you know the the money talk the
you don't need to fight on short notice
because you make so much money doing
this and the whole bar stool thing it's
be it's becoming a gimmick like the gigs
up let's focus on fighting let's focus
on getting back to fighting and and
kicking ass and it's the best time to do
it because they're taking the the myths
off of Patty Pim Patty piml there's he's
been built like there there's a there's
a period for guys with sugar Shan they
did this um with with other Fighters
that do this where they're they're going
to build that fighter in hopes that he's
the next big thing and then it's kind of
[__] get off the pot Patty's right
there UFC goes all right we did it man
we did it you're a big star you're a big
star before he came to us we've given
you the proper fight so the American fan
base tune in it's it's time to [__] her
get off the pot it's the last one here's
Tony Ferguson older guy Legend know
regard as one of the best 155s back in
the day this is a very winnable fight
for you after this it's it's time to get
going so his team knows that so like
let's just stop all the crap we're doing
um and and let's let's get to work he
came in in great shape he look good his
strikings better better still has a long
ways to go he's still leading with his
chin first instead of his you know
sitting back on his punches and there's
a there's a lot of that you could
criticize on his striking but um he got
he got a lot better from that jar Gordon
fight so there's Improvement there you
can tell he's been working hard his body
looked good he looked tight looked in
shape so you know the cornrow so he
looked he looked like a different
fighter he looked more focused this is
no win for him you know you're not going
to win any fans being Tony Ferguson but
uh it's all good but remember Patty was
was was eting Gary a little bit
obviously not with the cuck stuff but
with where people were you know he was
beloved and then he was so hated and
Patty's like how this happened overnight
when you go back and you look at the
steps like I get how they got to that
conclusion so now he that's gone there
again there's always be some people that
can't they just can't move on they have
whatever reason to hate Patty or or Ian
that's stuck in their brain and they
just can't they can't move on they're
not open-minded so then nean Gary took
that torch and he's here but again him
falling out that goes to the Wayside and
uh now it's Kobe comington but again
Kobe's not going to fight for a hot
second I assume so that there's going to
be somebody else that steps in you know
as far as the the hate wave goes so you
know those guys give people especially
Kobe Kobe Embraces it like Ian Gary
doesn't want to be hated Patty piml
definitely doesn't want to be you can
tell it bothers Patty piml he like he's
a nice nice kid man so he he doesn't
want that he just made some you know
he's young he made some errs Ian Gary
doesn't want that uh Kobe kind of does
that's his character right um and I've
always defend him saying it's a
character you know it's like being mad
at the Undertaker he's not really from
the underworld when you meet him you
know but then there is a line and it
takes a lot to for me to call somebody
out on this stuff but when Kobe went
after Leon's dad I was like I don't like
that but this is my theory with that I
think Colby in training remember he's
been out two years he's been out two
years he beat Hy mazal before that who
was also on his last leg then before
that obviously had the issues with Kamar
Usman
but you know Kobe's been training he
he's been in the camps and I bet his
team was like we're not moving how we
used to move my man you know like Father
time was like yo yo yo make America
great all that stuff the bag of stuff I
get it it's time Bubba and father time
comes for everybody it caught up to
Colby you can say ring Russ Don Cruz beg
the de for I do believe in ring rest but
he just didn't look like the co the
tenacious Kobe Compton the pace the
transitions the movement the fluidity it
just wasn't it wasn't there now it's not
Extreme as we saw with Tony Ferguson but
for Colby it's like it's just not there
also you're going taking two years off
and fighting Leon Edwards so that that
that would that magnifies everything
because Leon Edwards is firing all
cylinders he's in his prime he's one
what 13 in a row he's undefeated so it's
like
it's going to highlight that how much
Kobe's fallen off after two years you
know Co one of them got better and one
got worse and that looks it gets hugely
magnified when you take two years off
and one guy's been active and he happens
to be the best in the world at
welterweight so there still fights for
Kobe I I don't know what he wants to do
I know he called out Wonder
Boy they might do that
um you know the the day and age of him
fighting for titles is over this is the
third third one the UFC's tried to give
him I think anybody besides his mom and
dad would argue he didn't deserve that
title shot that was a little bit of WWE
is that this is where you know the line
gets blurred with the WW WWE stuff and
the UFC stuff um if Kobe didn't have the
mag Maga stuff if UFC wasn't Pro Maga if
UFC you know don't don't be don't be
tricked thinking that Trump being there
with Kid Rock and that the same cast
every time isn't planned that that's not
just Trump calling up Dana the the night
before the fight like I think I'm gonna
fly to Vegas and just check out coell no
no this is all planned that whole fan
base that's to that's to help Trump out
it's you know Dana supports him majorly
I'm not saying it's wrong I'm not saying
it's right but what I'm saying is that's
all
calculated Kobe comington getting a
title shot which doesn't make any sense
that's all calculated the AG stuff the
Trump all that's calculated to to to
bring to bring that fan base to get
these views did Kobe deserve that fight
over B Muhammad absolutely not come on
all this is this is where the WWE World
mixes in which I don't like I don't like
it you want this to be a real real sport
you don't have the guy because he can
help push this agenda or he can bring
these eyeballs gets a t of shot over a b
Muhammad who clearly deserves it more
than anybody then what are we doing you
know that that' be that' be that'd be
like the NFL going uh Cowboys are
America's team we got we got to give
them to the Super Bowl so refs make sure
you give them the calls would you watch
would you watch the NFL the same way no
man if they're playing your Eagles or
your Giants or Redskins like this sucks
dude they cow shouldn't be in the Super
Bowl we all know it and we know why the
NFL's pushing him because they're good
for Ratings you're like how this that's
not how this works the best team should
be in the Super Bowl the best fighter
should be fighting for the the world
championship the the champion should be
fighting the number one Contender Kobe's
not the number one Contender all this is
calculated all this is an agenda Trump
being there Kid Rock being there all
that Tucker Carlson being there none of
this is by coincidence all this is an
agenda it's Dan White's League all good
do what you want to do you know but it
it back just backfired just backfired
and for Kobe that that's his thing
attached his you know his wagon to to
that uh hitch so he has to double down
on that first thing he did when he got
on the mic was talk about border control
and all this stuff you're like you don't
to talk about the fight you don't talk
about like what's next in your career I
know k out Wonder Boy Thompson but you
don't to talk about that you're never
fight for a title
again and there's footage of uh Trump
walking out of the Arena while Kobe was
talking so people were like that's kind
of that sucks dude like Trump's
Savage Trump's Savage he doesn't
associate with loser
that's the Trump probably thinks he's
loot he's like oh hell no this dude's
pushing border control and [__] and he's
pushing you know meet me at the White
House all like you think col's team's
calling up Trump to go to marago not the
UFC all that's all that's this isn't
some conspiracy like Flat Earth there
all that is that's easy stuff man this
is all an agenda but Leon Edwards
doesn't play the agenda he's a real
fighter know wait hold on because he's
with Trump and all this and Trump sting
cide and Tucker Carlson and Kid Rock I
don't give a [__] I'm kick him in the
face you see Co I know that sucks you
know all that that'd be like the NFL
that's no different the NFL pushing
forcing the Dallas Cowboys to the Super
Bowl we they have no they just got their
ass will buy the bills they have no
business going to the Super Bowl just
because they're the most famous team
that'd be the NBA pushing the Lakers
they're good come on man they're better
than the Nuggets no Joe kage isn't as
entertaining he doesn't get as many
eyeballs better than
LeBron so we we got to keep the sport in
the UFC we I know the WWE and the whole
TKO thing but we can't go we can't go
that route and that's this is and you
know this is the first sign they're
going a little bit of that route it's
heartbreaking it's not good because guys
like below Muhammad don't get their shot
he should we'll see what they do next
but Danel was like I don't make fights
you know after you know any major
pay-per-views which he always does but
and clearly Bal deserves this they want
to screw him over they they would toss
uh sha cot at him which is so messed up
and shot's just waiting just waiting in
the in the shadows to really
beat balal or Leon I'd love to see sha
cot Bal I think that's a very tough
fight for a shaat even though he's 18
and0 18 finishes he's never gone to the
distance he's a absolute Maniac Savage
he doesn't fought a guy like b or Leon
like Leon's gotten so much better man
his takedown defense his grappling he's
a real mixed martial arts just happens
to be outstanding at striking so always
think Striker but he can do it all
taking Colby down taking Usman down you
know um so yeah that that that that was
weird um the whole week was weird I
don't like the the negative stuff I I
don't know if we need to do that I don't
know if we need to do that it wasn't
always like this
it wasn't always like this and you know
these Fighters are a product of what the
UFC encourages you know they've seen
guys like Conor McGregor um you know
when khabib jumped out of the ring the
Octagon all all that stuff the whole
Conor McGregor the the negative nasty
talk these young Fighters are going wait
he's the most famous most paid guy of
all time that's what that's the game
plan youf see goes that's the game plan
that's what we want oh okay
D going now we don't like that negative
stuff we don't like when we didn't like
when Jon Jones and DC fought that weird
press conference at MGM weird you used
it non-stop to the buildup
yep D dupes and uh Strickland can you
believe that happened well we sat two
guys right next to each other who makes
SC chart Dana does yeah can you believe
I oh my God I can't believe oh my can
you believe they did did that I can't
believe I sat him there this is insane
dude did we catch out on HD can we play
this soon can you play it in HD as soon
as this pay-per-view wraps just over and
over online over and over that's that
this is all
planned now does the UFC go up to
Strickland and do Poli season and go hey
boys you guys are right there well let's
sell this thing won't you guys fight no
they're not doing that they know
Strickland is a wild boy they
know uh drus is not
shy and they assume it's kind of The
Perfect Storm for something like this to
happen guarantee someone's like hey hey
strickling D ddpr are talking yep y get
the camera over there yep here we go
here we go this is what we want here we
go all right you got the HD on it yep
and three two one there we go cut it get
it to the cam you know that's all the
doing yeah they're not they're not going
up to them going hey boys let's do this
they're not doing that UFC is going this
is disgusting because they got a save
face they got a save face because they
have all these sponsors and ESPN's like
dude what is happening why why are these
guys doing this one guy's talking about
some guy's dead dad you have Fighters
fighting the stands what are we doing
you's like it's insane man I don't know
what we're going to do these guys are
savages it's [__] it's stupid it's
stupid
it's like the warden leaving a a rope in
the in the cell and be like I can't I
can't believe he committed suicide man
well who left the Rope we did I I left
the rope in the cell this is nuts dude
we do not condone this we absolutely
this is not what we want we are a real
sport we are an absolute real sport
there's nothing this is
crazy it's just all you know it's going
down such a weird Road it's entertaining
it's entertaining I'd rather like this
stuff this whatever yeah they're
Fighters man like real Fighters
Strickland's a real dude you know I
preferred this over the the below the
belt punch your dad I'll see him in hell
and that making it personal because
that's not personal that's two guys that
don't like each other and they have to
fight okay cool that's whatever Fighters
going to fight but when it gets nasty
and Co with Co and then Kobe doubles
down on it I've always defended him I
always tell you guys this he's a good
guy it's like being mad at the
Undertaker not from the underworld then
when he doubles down on it was like no
his dad did this like God dang dude and
then you had a performance like that but
here's my theory he did that this whole
rant is wrapped up with Kobe did that
because his team knew Kobe was not the
same version that he was two years ago
and they got to do something to get in
Leon Edward's head because he's too good
he's going to beat Colby everywhere if
Colby and if Leon comes correct he's
going to beat the [__] out Kobe so we
got to get him out of that mindset we
got to get him to fight emotional we got
to get him come forward by any means
necessary the 's a professional didn't
fall for it was able to calm down he
said he was crying you know after that
was so mad but pulled himself together
he's a professional and beat the [__]
out of Kobe Kobe's team and and Kobe
knew like I'm a I'm a shell of myself
and we're fighting a prim Leon Edwards
we got to do
something you know he probably ran that
by somebody like it's going to piss him
off that's what it takes and Kobe's like
I don't care people hate me
already and the whole stick you know
when he walked in the arena they're
cheering for him they weren't cheering
for him after you better be able to back
that stuff up you can go that deep and
dark you better back it up horrible
Fight Man bad fight for Colby I I just
for Colby you know financially I don't
know where he's at uh careerwise as far
as title shots it's over the the new
waves coming in so damn hot and there's
so much talent is Kobe gonna take a
fight with shot let's say the UFC went
all right all right Kobe just fought for
a title probably didn't deserve it uh if
you want to fight for another title you
you got to fight two guys it's G be
shott and Ian Gary ye it's tough man
does he want to go down that
road you know is that is that the plan I
don't
know I I I don't I just think it's it's
um you know I think there's two guys on
this card who are probably done it's
Kobe Covington and Tony Ferguson
Ferguson for like sure man here's a
problem with now let's talk about Tony
and Patty
pinlin Tony Ferguson even though he had
David gogins in his corner and you know
his cardio was there but you know David
Goggins can't help in th in those
regards
but the problem with Tony Ferguson is if
the UFC Cuts him which they probably
well if the UFC Cuts him Tony's such a
dog he signs with be knuckle do you want
to see Tony and bear knuckle that's the
kind of guy he is bear knuckle is right
up his alley so do you want to see Tony
go from the U would you rather him
continue to fight in the UFC if that's
even an option or would you rather see
him go on over to beer knuckle where
it's the most brutal thing you
know yeah I don't know I'm sure me and K
talk about him fighing the kid and he'll
defend all here here's the issue we we
don't know Tony's personal financial
situation we don't we don't know if he's
good all this guy knows is fighting so
it's easy for everybody in here and for
Brian and his private jets and his Rich
Dad to go he should just stop everyone
says this about Fighters well he and the
community says this the fans say this
didn't he should just stop what should
he do it's all he knows it's the only
way he feeds his
family well that's on him he didn't set
things up he can't the UFC makes it very
tough tonywood didn't come up like a
Patty pinmill or sugar Shan in that era
where there was twitch and sponsors like
that you limit them to rebok so that
cuts them at the
knees so he's supposed to allocate
resources to plan over but he has but
you want to be Allin to be a world
champion so so it's this it's this weird
thing it's so easy for us to go he needs
to stop yeah how's he going to feed his
kids you going to pay for it you going
to pay for it I can't I got to few my
own kids who's going to cover Tony's
bills who's going to cover his mortgage
his car
payments his wife his insurance remember
the UFC don't give you insurance not for
the family who's going to cover all that
and we're all quick to go he needs to
stop you stop doing the job you're doing
right now and completely reinvent
yourself and not only do that but at the
same time make a living doing it right
away that covers the bills that's why
these guys keep fighting
this is why this lawsuit that these guys
are going against UFC is so important
these guys should be set you think if
Tony said he would have taken seven
losses in a row
no that's why Conor's not foaming at the
mouth to get back in there he's good all
these guys should be a guy at Tony's
level should be
good but he's not because the pay
structure they screw these guys over and
we all we're so quick that that guy
should stop he should retire okay and do
what be a kickboxing
instructor making $10 a [__] session
that doesn't pay his bills he's been
making six figures seven figures for
last 10
years you know so so quick everyone so
quick yeah guy needs to stop and do
what it's too easy we're all quick to
judge these guys they need to stop they
need to stop fighting oh yeah you're
going to pay mortgage nope so that that
for Tony it's tough you never hear me
that guy needs to stop we all do this we
he guy needs to stop it's like telling K
you need to stop doing standup I can't
man I have to pay the bills I know but
you need to
stop okay are you going to cover what I
would make on the road oh you're not
well I got to keep doing
it but it's physical health I know you
think Tony's worried about that no he's
worried about feeding his
family yeah so he put love my fans
supporters you are all effing
fire I met lots of you T I keep the
faith m mfers one foot in front of the
other remember what I said crew champ
he's still not giving up so how could he
I know he's do what what do you want
these guys to do they know one thing
it's punching and kicking people in the
face he needs to
stop my question is and do
what you cover his mortgage it's tough
to see man that's the way this this this
this world goes Bryce Mitchell's in a
tough spot you know took that took a
awful matchup on short notice against
Josh EMT and Josh EMT coming off a
two-fight losing streak over the dogs of
the division absolutely starches Bryce
Mitchell puts him in a different reality
yeah he's shaking seizing up that was so
scared to watch you's like hell yeah
zoom in on that yeah yeah hey can we get
Rogan in there a postf fight uh
interview with him is there anyway while
he's shaking up like that how crazy is
it is there no rules to this game
anymore are we just Savages is everyone
just barbaric at this
point think about this weekend man I'm
not I'm not even trying to be negative
it's just the state of the sport we're
in it's this
weird uh you know attitude eror that
we're in it's this weird kind of dark
these guys go after you know the his
dead dad Bryce Mitchell's twitch and the
showing it guys are fighting inside the
Octagon you got Trump there it's just
this whole weird like just I don't know
it just doesn't make you feel good it's
a weird thing it's a weird vibe man I
don't know how we got here I don't know
how we got here no
clue that main card was not great for
all the
buildup was not
great Josh EMT kicked it off with a
ridiculous knockout Patty pilet Tony Fon
we expect did more of a Patty we thought
we I thought he got to finish in the
first there he dominated him the whole
fight sha cot you know basically took
two rounds of finished Wonder Boy UFC
wasn't happy about that that supposed to
be a very one-sided fight Pantoja bran
Roy valal one-sided 5045 ahe across the
board panta is too much for Brandon
Brandon's cardio was still insane but
just didn't didn't have enough skill set
to compete with panta so that one was
God let's get this over with all right
finally the main event Leon Ard Kobe
kington decision
Leon in NE never in any trouble just
completely dismantled Colby col's on his
back foot the whole time was like three
for 10 or three for 15 on takedowns Leon
took him down there no one's was ever
really in horrible danger than any of
that that fight was a rough main card
man rough main card weird way to end the
year it's been a great year for the UFC
been a great year but this one this one
uh hit the hit the mark what do you got
Jen all all righty
um also over the weekend Jake Paul he
fought that guy Andre August who's like
a like a I guess pretty decent
professional boxer yeah he has F two
years you know uppercut I don't know why
Jake does it I don't know why Jake does
it there's a reason why Jake his brother
everyone me everyone blasted that
knockout out because nobody watched it
nobody knew he was fighting and Jake
didn't even promote it himself he said
like he just wants to get experience so
I know which kudos to him and all the
respect in the world I don't get it like
what's the end game Jake to you fight
this guy
that you know vicious knockout that's
cool
but this stuff doesn't work anymore it's
rigged it's getting boring at this point
okay
but for Jake just keep beating up the
old MMA guys call it Tony
Ferguson let Tony get that payday to
make the most money more people tune but
and and get eyeballs no one's watching
him fight these boxers we never heard of
I don't give a [__] that guy was 40 and0
I don't I'm not tuning
in he's doing it for his own ego I guess
or he's listening to the the naysayers
fight a real boxer beat a real boxer
okay Dereck Brunson said feed me Jake
Paul these dudes he's fine don't want to
fight I'd watch
that yeah
anyways um so this also happened over
over the weekend which kind of slipped
my mind as well but Anthony Pettis
versus Benson Henderson in karate combat
did you watch it I watched it I just
watched like the highlights those boys
were scrapping yeah they were going at
it it was fun to watch Pettis still
looks damn good mhm and that's like his
third win over Benson so that's right
Benson just can't beat him that's his
Achilles heel yeah this Sport's actually
pretty fun to
watch yeah this is the one that got me
into it
m Benson and uh Pettis look great they
were scrapping man yeah so you know Jon
Jones hates Colby Covington they were
roommates before at some point but uh
after after Leon's win he tweeted about
Leon buy he wanted to buy him Leon
Edwards I couldn't be more happy for you
as an American champion in this game I
salute you this was truly a job well
done let me know if I can gift you a
motorcycle or something for Christmas
feel like I owe you one Leon's like I
don't drive motorcycles and then someone
mentioned of Harley vrod and he goes L
would dope on a Harley vrod yeah I agree
but man whatever he wants it' be my
pleasure mhm and this is pretty crazy
this is from ESPN bet and ESPN MMA
someone bet 35,000 on Patty sha cot Cody
and
Leon um they I think they're all favored
to win anyways but 35k on all of them
and they all won yeah but 35 to win what
what do you mean no so bet 35,000 on
Patty to win 35,000 on Sha every to to
win I wonder how much you won since they
were favored you know it kind
of hold up you're talking about Patty
was a what 4 to1 favorite shot was six
to one here we go so Leon was minus the
only close one so shot was A- 650 you're
making no money on that Patty was a
minus 310 you're making no money Cody
minus 198 Cody so the Cody and the Leon
Edwards was his best bet so he probably
made decent money yeah I mean still made
him a lot of money 35,000 on each
fighter
scared bet on UFC like that because you
never know what's happening
yeah uh so we kind of talked about this
a little bit so UFC 299 dude this March
9th card is
fire so Ali versus Vera 2 is going to
headline it and then this was pretty
cool to find out that Michael Venom
Paige actually signed with UFC and he's
fighting Kevin Holland there love i'
love it because I bet uh pfl backed up
the Brinks truck for Michael Venom pagee
he went I gotta go see where I'm at I
got to go to the big dog I got to go to
the UFC and freaking Kevin Holland is
not an easy that's a great that's a fun
fight that's a great fight and then
Michael venage put out like a promo
beforehand did you see it where you open
a bag two gloves pfl and UFC and he's
like grabbing one of them but you can't
see what he did well now we know people
are going to be surprised how good uh
Michael V page is if you haven't seen
him he's freaking talented yeah and you
already talked about this but yeah so I
Machado Gary and Jeff Neil same card and
then this I would hope Ian Machado Gary
does I'm just calling Ian Gary for God's
sakes I hope Ian Gary I'm not doing that
I'm not doing that I refuse to
acknowledge that yep I I think Ian Gary
I hope he drops the you know the shirt
with the mug shot yeah just like like
hey I'm fighting Jeff Neil I apologize
for that the Shir thing that was out of
line like like I'll see you in the Octon
how about just don't do everything your
wife yeah whatever your wife says do the
opposite pleas cuz my my question for
you is how's that going
terrible Yong versus Peter
Yan same card this is a stacked card
stacked yeah um and also another badass
one great fight Gilt Burns Jack Del out
love this fight yeah great fight for
JDM um so we kind of we talked to us off
camera but so Deontay Wilder is fighting
Joseph Parker your boy this weekend on
Saturday and I have the headlines like
Wilder versus Parker I'm sorry wild it
was it said when we brought it up it
said Wilder vers it said Wilder and
Joshua like oh [__] the main just
playing he's fighting Joseph Parker the
other guy's fighting here day of reckon
Deontay Wilder Anthony Joshua on same
fight card they got to do that though
you know or how about you two just fight
each other yeah so but I would assume
the winners and you assume to be Anthony
Joshua and Deontay W they both win and
then they call each other out yeah and
they're they're in talks after this to
fight in March at sometime in Joseph
Parker's no punk though no he's awesome
that's our
boy
um this is kind of crazy so Darren
Elkins apparently he was doing a
Jiu-Jitsu thing practice whatever and
broke both his tibula and fibula TI and
fibula what was he doing it was a freak
accident i s my tibia in fibula in my
right leg by freak acccident during juu
last night wow so that's that's a pretty
devastating hot especially at his age
out for a hot second
mhm all righty oh you always talk good
about Britney Palmer like she's a super
talented painter and everything too
right super smart yeah so she announced
her she's going to be retiring from the
UFC after like six I don't know how many
years was 16 or something like that good
for her man yeah is arani retired too I
think she just didn't announce it I
don't know I know she had a kid so I
don't know what's going on with that
yeah so she was with the UFC for 16
years I had no idea it was that long
long time
yeah so she announced her retirement at
the MMA Awards good MMA
Awards uh this one's just weird so
Charles olera I guess people started
rumors that he was dating some girl they
do this with him all the time yeah he's
fine and he he's like what he's like
what and then apparently they were
dating and then he's like what and then
they broke up recently he's like
what the Real Housewives of the UFC
trying to get some together Charles
Oliver and Ice spice break up he's all
what yeah
what it's so crazy how these things pop
up out of nowhere and they get traction
too yeah she wasn't yeah she's she's
she's a cool one
yeah people then they put it together
like she was in Brazil recently on
tour damn this might be a short episode
there's not that many cor Uh current
events that's all right this the last
one of the Year fellas It's Been a Good
Year yeah
uh yeah the last one of the year you
don't have a UFC to what
UFC January 26 no January 20th is a
pay-per-view but I think January 16th
you have uh Johnny Walker here we go
January 13 13th and on the 20th you have
the pay-per-view I'll be doing companion
with Rogan for that the one in Toronto
strickly
dupes and you you definitely think you
take strict
no I'm not I what do you mean oh I
thought cuz we were talking before no
I've never said Strickland okay never
uhuh I this is the toughest fight to
call I don't know I this is one I cannot
call maybe as we get closer or something
you know I'll do more research on it but
I can't call this one Strickland dup dup
is so awkward so powerful I don't know
and his strickling is is he that damn
good was is he just an off night and
wasn't didn't want the fight we don't
know it's a very tough fight for both
guys guys tough tough fight the odds if
there odds on that it should be minus
105 both
Fighters uh I'll check in one second but
another fun fight for this weekend is uh
one Championship on Friday this the 22nd
tan
4:30 uh 7:30 a.m. eastern yeah so that
not on Amazon no
no um you said stricklin dupes yeah
what's the
odds
there it
is minus 150 strong trickin plus 125
yeah that's going to move I bet it's
even money but the fight come
mhm that's how it should be that's such
a tough fight such a good fight so tough
to call I don't
know I don't know as of
now is that it brother that's it bro we
got a ads oh crap I totally forgot about
the ads holy moly
um sorry damn dude my bad oh no now
we're have to do like four in a
row yeah damn CH wish you would produce
this thing my bad dude my
bad see are you drinking this morning I
mean yep
truly
well listen all I want for the holidays
is chin to stop drinking and do his job
this year the NBA action this week new
cers can score 150 instantly in bonus
bets for betting just five bucks an
instant dub just for you you got the
Lakers surgeon they won the inseason
tournament the the Champs celebrating
with champagne which is a little weird
whatever my nuggets going to beat the
brakes off of them download the
draftking Sportsbook app right now use
the code shop show new customers can get
150 instantly and bonus bets for betting
just five buckaroos on basketball only
on draftking Sports we with a code shop
show the crown is yours DraftKings hit
it boys who wants to take it gambling
problem call 1800 Gambler or visit www.1
800 gambler. net in New York call 8778
heny or text heny 467 369 in Connecticut
help is available for problem gambling
call 8887895118
je meter all right let's all do these
all in a row the holidays are finally
here let's stuff our faces eat like
there's no tomorrow forget your diet
shop till we drop in guys I have the
perfect stocking stuffer for you doesn't
have to be a stocking stuffer wrap this
bad boy up like it's a real gift show
some respect I'm talking about meter
it's a slick smart meat thermometer that
tracks the temperature of your meat and
lets you know when it's ready to come
out of the oven or your grill all right
you just put it in there it let you know
exact medium rare rare outside that
you're not eating real meat if it's well
done what are we doing the app even
estimates how long your cook will take
and gives you a countdown so you know
how long you have to kick back and spend
time with your boys you get an alert on
your phone when your food is ready to
eat perfect to use in the oven Grill
even in the smoker I know a lot of you
like air frying and you can definitely
use meter in that as well super simple
super easy you'll get the perfect
consistent results all right uh monitor
monitor your prime rib chicken pork
chops steak whatever you you got man
it's all in the app um you can be
consistent with it sometimes I'm a
little dicey sometimes it's medium rare
sometimes rare I'm just going off the
the the eye test don't take all that
guess work out of it all right this is
the perfect tool for your holiday
cooking also makes the perfect gift
someone who loves a Cooker grill I need
to get my dad this he cooked the salmon
way too much the other night shop
meter.com for the best kitchen tool out
there that's m a t r.com check out their
brand sping new product all right um be
stressfree this season that's meter.com
all right to check out their brands make
a new product meter.com get your meat
right just two more
Shopify listen when I started podcasting
in online store we selling F the kid
merch out of my garage me and my brother
would do it and then business started to
boom and we need to step our game up and
that's why we started using Shopify so
easy all because I use Shopify CH Ching
all right um Shopify is a global mob
Commerce platform that helps you sell at
every stage of your business from launch
your online stage shop which we did to
the first real life store stage all the
way to did we just hit a millon order
stage still not there Shopify is there
to help you grow with your auction
autograph apparel selling Sleek skis
whatever it is car part Shopify helps
you sell everywhere from their allinone
e-commerce platform to their inperson
POS system wherever whatever you're
selling Shopify got you covered shopop
helps you turn browsers into buyers with
the internet's best converting checkout
up to 36% better compared to other
leading Commerce platforms all right
Shopify Powers 10% of all e-commerce in
the US shopify's Global force behind all
birds rothy brooklynin uh millions of
other entrepreneurs of every size across
175 countries because business that grow
grow with Shopify sign up for $1 per
month trir at shopify.com shab all
lowercase that's shop AU all lowercase
go to shopify.com Shob right now to grow
your business no matter what stage
you're in shopify.com Shob lowercase
CH this episode of the shop show the
last one of the year is brought to you
by my friends the best product I use I'm
talking about that create them at happy
hippo they got gummies taffies powders
tablets they got freaking highly
concentrated energy shots regular shots
they got it all they got the K dips if
you want to get your creat them that way
you take the guest work out don't trust
just anybody I trust happy hitb I've
been using them for years all right
these are the bees knes when it comes to
creatum they got it all free guys you
get 20% off go to go to freaking happy
hippo.com promp code is thick 23 thick
with three C's thick 23 get 20% off for
Life anybody can use that get the best
CR on the planet get your mind right
it's happy hippo.com
is that it that's it oh I'm off for the
holidays but I picked back up on tour
dates in Nashville one night only
January 25th that's a Thursday in
Nashville and then uh January 26 27th
I'm in Austin Texas so Nashville the
25th Austin Texas 26th and 27th get Jo
tickets at thick boo.com
uh is it this week or this week we're
dropping the new episode of Toontown
it's all about my lightning it's been a
beast fam um I bought a car off the
internet without looking into it we had
some issues but it's a generation 2
Lightning the Paul Walk one we're doing
some fun stuff with it um the first
episode uh of the lightning on Toontown
which is actually episode two uh comes
out this week so stay tuned for that
it's a fun we got lot this fun stuff in
the works as well with Toontown so could
to be more excited but Nashville Austin
see you January 25th 26th through the
27th love you guys can't thank you
enough this is the last show of the year
so thank you guys for liking subscribing
if you haven't please subscribe please
like leave a comment whatever you want
to do uh couldn't do the show without
you guys the staff here have a great
great uh New Year happy holidays thank
you guys so much for allowing me to do
this um I can't thank you guys enough
love you guys be safe have a great
holiday take care of each other be nice
out there I love you guys see
you
that